-Hello, Elizabeth. How are you
-I am so happy to be here.
How you guys doing?
-Well, I'm very excited
to talk about the show,
but I also am very excited
about this.
You are joining us
right after your first
dentist appointment
in -- in months.
-That's right.
-And we are just dying
to know how it went.
-I have a temporary crown.
I had three cracks
in a back tooth
that have sort of been achin
for like six months.
[ Laughs ]
And I finally thought,
"I better go get it handled.
I can actually smile, mostly
Like, you can see
it's a little off still.
And I had a really hard time
putting my lipstick on,
but I think I did all right.
I don't know. I can't tell
-I bet if we hadn't brought it
up, no one would've noticed.
-Thank you.
So thank you for that then
-I meant every word of it.
This is -- I want to ask
about "Press Your Luck."
This is a game show
from the '80s.
And, first of all, it looks like
a lot of fun to host.
Second, is it weird
looking at old episodes
where you are not just
with an audience of people
but an audience of people
having a very good time
and projecting their joy?
-Yeah. I -- I actually --
I read a tweet, recently,
from a "Press Your Luck" fan
that said,
"Elizabeth is always yelling."
Thank you
for that judgment, one.
Two, it's because the audience
loves this show.
They are raucous.
I mean, you know, they're --
They're so happy when someon
wins a car, as am I.
And they're so happy to se
the Whammy, as am I.
And so it's really, really loud.
And the idea
of making the show --
In the future, I mean --
I know that we can get
contestants in there,
but, you know,
I will definitely miss
the live, in-studio audience
as I imagine you do, as well
getting through your jokes
every night.
-I do.
I feel like a lot of my joke
are getting Whammies --
based on not having
an audience here.
Was this a show
you watched growing up?
Because I have a lot of memories
of "Press Your Luck."
-Oh. It was the
after-school, like, specia
that me and my sibs
needed to watch every day.
We -- I loved --
When they first presented it
to me, I was like, "Wait.
They're going to
bring back this show
that was my favorite thing
in the world?"
And then, also, the Whammies
We -- We kept a lot of
the old animation style.
So it's got this
really kitschy Whammy to i
that just brings back
so many memories.
It was one of those things where
we just piled onto the couch
We ate Lucky Charms,
which we were not allowed.
That was, like,
our Saturday morning cereal,
but we'd sneak it.
And we would pick out
all of the marshmallows
out of the Lucky Charms
and watch "Press Your Luck."
That is like -- Those are, like,
gold memories in my brain.
-It seems like it must be a jo
to do this job now,
but, of course, you did no
set out to be a game-show host
It's sort of a nice byproduc
of being an actor.
Was that something you alway
thought you were going to do
is pursue acting?
-Oh, no, I didn't decide
to be an actor --
Really, I didn't decide
to be an actor
until I was halfway
through college.
And I thought I would be
Diane Sawyer or Barbara Walters.
I wanted to be --
I wanted to basic--
Or be you.
I wanted to do that job.
And then I got to play
to great effect on "30 Rock,
and in many other roles now --
I have played a newscaster
I thought I would do,
like, broadcast news.
-You are very good
as a comedy newscaster.
I -- Maybe that means
that you wouldn't
have been perfect
for the real thing,
but you are as good at comedy --
You are the Diane Sawyer
of comedy newscasters.
-Thank you. Yeah, they --
I was very happy
when Tina Fey sent me
to North Korea
to do the news there.
-And you actually went.
A lot of people thought
that was green screen,
but you did actually --
-People don't realize.
I was in -- Yeah.
I actually went there.
-You -- You've also have
made quite a career
as a producer.
You have a production compan
called "Brownstone" that -
among other things,
the "Pitch Perfect" franchise --
has tried really hard
to give voice
to, you know, especially women
and people who have less
of a voice in this industry,
you know, still do.
But I was wondering
how much you've seen it change
in the last ten years
that you've been doing it?
-I actually think
in the last --
I've been doing it, yeah,
a little more than a decade now.
And I think, actually,
we've made a lot
of incredible progress.
I think that the amount
of television and content
that's being created
is really incredible
in this moment in time anyway.
But making
especially feature films
that feature large casts
of women
is still very, very rare.
And so to have made
"Pitch Perfect"
and "Charlie's Angels" --
I mean, if that's my legac
of creating things
and telling women's stories,
female-fronted stories --
We also have "Shrill,"
starring Aidy Bryant.
And I just think
I will be very happy
if that's my legacy
in Hollywood.
-It's a pretty good legacy
and it's really well-deserved.
Before you go, I want to ask
because we both
are parents of two boys.
Yours are a little older.
How is --
How is school going
as we now are in the fall?
-Well, I am still having trouble
getting them to wear pants
-Yep.
-And -- [ Laughs ]
And my son wore
a ninja costume
last week for school.
Just -- I just walked in,
and he was in a full ninja
And the best part
about it, Seth,
was I sat there
for a minute to be like,
"Is this okay that
he's in a ninja costume?"
And then
they went around the room,
and another kid
was wearing a ninja costume.
Like, full, like, Cobra Ka
with the red and everything.
And my son was like, "What?!
Like, looked at me, like,
"That's MY thing!"
And it turns out
he wasn't the only one.
[ Laughs ]
-As they get older,
they'll realize ninjas
shouldn't really present
themselves on Zoom like that
You know? You have to be
a little bit more secretive.
-Little more secretive. Yeah
He was in the full black
ninja costume.
The fact that this other kid
was also wearing a ninja costume
just broke me.
-Yeah.
I walked in the other day,
and my son was, like,
sitting on his side,
like, on his elbow
wearing a straw hat.
And he looked like
a Carly Simon record album
So we're all -- Everybody'
getting good looks at their kids
that we wouldn't get on
a normal school day.
-We're really delving into
some, like, psyche, you know
It's -- It's like what the
wished school was actually like.
You know?
-Absolutely. Hey.
All the best to your family.
Congrats on the show.
It's always lovely
to talk to you, Elizabeth.
-Thank you. "Press Your Luck
on Thursday, everybody!